to shoot these stunts for Mission
Impossible with Tom there are no limits
so we become a little bit more
adventurous every time
Tom's doing a sport very few people on
this planet do it's called speed flying
it's a very beautiful and delicate sport
but it also is one of the most dangerous
sports in the world while it may look
similar speed flying is not skydiving
skydiving is fairly predictable speed
flying is incredibly unpredictable
it's a very small canopy racing down the
mountains just feet off the ground they
sort of Crosswinds could put Tom in
peril
we're gonna do spirals
and we're Landing in an incredibly high
speed over 80 kilometers an hour
we've been training for a few years now
[Music]
and we're always looking for what's the
most dynamic way to shoot this
coming up with the stunt is only one of
the technical challenges the other is
putting a camera in a place that you can
see where Tom is operating the speedway
can't get close to this with a
helicopter or a drone so we had to
develop a gimbal system flying along
with Tom you had cameras hanging off of
both sides being operated in a
helicopter what's going to work is
here's you here's me this is what we
need
that's one of the things they're doing
practical action we are at diversity of
weather
too dangerous
the wind's dropping now it's only going
to get better let's go let's go let's go
I'm ready
confirming you have pictures good
[Applause]
Thomas Airborne Thomas airborne
flying very close to rocks looks quite
beautiful
behind the scenes we were all in
absolute terrible
Landing Tom had to be flying towards the
camera vehicle that meant that Tom had
to hit the exact mark
or it can end it disaster
[Music]
it is truly a one-of-a-kind Adventure